[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by anara Simone AKA
Sandra in the Midnight Club we're gonna
be talking spoilers so make sure you
watch the whole show first before we
watch this interview Anar how you doing
today I'm good I'm good how are you I'm
doing great I'm so excited to have you
on definitely one of my favorite people
in the philaniverse now we can actually
officially say you're yeah you're one of
the Legends you got two under your belt
now which is awesome so people who loved
you oh no problem and people loved you
from Midnight Mass it's exciting to see
you in this was there anything you
brought from that experience that you
learned to the Midnight Club mm-hmm
um this is like the same question I got
asked a panel on Comic-Con and I'm just
going to say the same answer because
it's so true
um in a midnight mass I was working with
a lot of just like incredibly talented
people who were so generous and so kind
on and offset
um and so I think one thing that was
important to me was to be a generous
actor and I and I and like I never
thought about it before but it's
something that I want to continue
throughout my career and I hope I
brought to the Midnight Club as well
um I remember specifically I was doing a
scene with Robert Longstreet uh in the
trailer and he's like the nicest human
being ever but um and I was so nervous
but when I was doing the scene I was so
calm because it felt like he was giving
so much
um in his performance and he was such a
giving human being but also a giving
actor um within the workspace and so
that's something that I think I hope to
bring to all my projects oh yeah that
that's a great aspiration to have and
yeah that's a great thing to learn and
it's awesome that Robert long streets
also in this show which is another great
flanniverse person but also when first
reading the script for the Midnight Club
what was the most important thing you
wanted to make sure you got right about
Sandra like what jumped off the page too
yeah
I mean
upon first read and a lot of people have
come to him and like have been like gee
I hated her but like
um I wanted to make sure that she was
understood because I think that's all
that she wants in her life and you know
she can be very stubborn
um but I think one thing I hope to take
away from Sandra like even playing her
is that she's at the end she becomes a
very open book and an open person and I
think she um allows other people to
print on her and she can print on them
and it kind of like she couldn't create
her herself without being
so
um harsh um but yeah I guess she's just
she stays true to herself and I think
that's really important but she also
allows for growth
um which I think that's something that a
lot of people or me included you know
you wanna you wanna be like no this is
the way this is the way but um there's a
lot of other ways out there and you can
learn I think
yeah totally and I think that's what's
great about her character Arc like you
just mentioned about the growth that
goes on with her now playing the
character of Sandra though who has a
strong faith being in that character's
head do you have to be thinking on faith
terms a lot with her choices you're
making as an actor with her character
like was that kind of a different
experience
um I mean sometimes I mean I did from a
minute mask she was also religious I did
read like The Bible and all this stuff
oh wow yeah I'm not particularly
religious but um I mean it does
influence certain ways people behave but
I think it's just like like it's just a
character trait you know what I mean it
doesn't have to control who she is as a
human being and I think that's kind of
what you see at first glance is like oh
she's just religious she's you know
she's doing all this and this but she's
more than just what she believes if that
makes sense oh yeah no that's that's a
great answer and I I totally got that
vibe from Sandra too so also interesting
about this character Sandra is episode
four she gets the big Sandra episode she
gets to tell her story give me a kiss uh
and it's this old school detective story
now before we even get into that I'm
wondering as I re-watch the show there's
a moment Sandra looks at Spence's arm
and sees the blood clot before she tells
a story
um do you think
she would she have told the story if she
didn't see the blood caught on his arm
in that moment
to be honest I think she was I mean that
was something that pushed her to do it
anymore you know because she's like a
nervous anxious person and like yeah I
think Sandra I think she's always got a
plan and I think that she had like this
thought out and she was like nervous and
scared I was like am I gonna do it am I
not gonna do it and I think that was
something that like pushed her a little
more into telling the story yeah yeah
yeah that that makes sense I like that
and it's interesting speaking of the
story I love this character you play of
Alice Palmer talk to me about the
inspiration for your betrayal of her was
there any maybe films or characters you
kind of were inspired by to pull off
Alice Palmer I mean Mike and Michael
from minori who was the director of that
episode gave like a whole list of films
to watch
um I Remember Loving Casablanca and then
I watched brick which is like a new
telling of like the film Noir situation
um but yeah she wasn't specifically
based off of one person but I think that
I just took from a lot of the things I
watched and we tried to also we did a
lot of rehearsals for that episode we
tried to kind of get the Cadence and all
that stuff so that was quite nice I mean
but the clothes and the hair did it all
really I mean like oh come on you're
selling yourself short no you killed it
and it was so cool to see you do that
character and it was probably one of the
most exciting episodes for me because it
felt kind of more out there which I
liked and I like to uh
the chair getting interrogated by Jake
and we have this heavy rain pouring I
thought it just looked amazing too so
what did this actually look like on set
for you and was this the most
challenging scene yet for you in the
philaniverse
I mean yeah I think so because it's like
a very specific style and I remember
like I was so nervous and Chris was so
nervous because we're like okay we're
just gonna do it as many times as we
need to and Michael feminiore who's like
absolutely fantastic was so like helpful
um but on set it looked
pretty pretty cool pretty gnarly like
even in the detective scene where I'm
with um Heather the rain was real and
like Chris was really standing there
like getting drenched um until like all
the really beautiful like cinematography
and like little things that are put in
it from Michael and from the um DP and
stuff like that
um it kind of looked like that on set
which is really cool yeah and that it
looked amazing it came out awesome and
it was good too because it's just that
working with your guys performances was
something I'll always remember and
what's interesting too is you mentioned
earlier in the interview about the
character's growth
after the story she says dispense I'm
sorry for being a bit of an idiot and
people who treat you poorly you can't
love God and hate love do you think
Sandra had a big character growth moment
here in particular or was she like
already that way and maybe just slipped
up a bit with the whole Spence fight
I mean I think she's somebody who always
wants like what's best for everybody and
that can sometimes look like her being
like let me control it let me let me
like tell you how you can have like the
best thing happen to you in the perfect
life
um and I think that was a really
important moment for her to understand
that you know people are going down
different paths and things like that
um so I do think that was like a very
pivotal moment um especially in her
relationship with Spence because it was
quite strained before but yeah yeah for
sure I think that yeah that was a huge
moment and yeah it really was one of the
strongest relationships was this Sandra
and Spence relationship during the show
and seeing that change as it goes on
then
Sandra has this big episode so far but
also has a huge moment episode nine
where we find out she's the one who's
healing and not terminal lymphoma so now
for you though as a viewer as anara do
you believe the ritual healed are what's
your view on that debate
um as anara
I mean I don't know you always want to
believe like that there's like some like
you know magic going on
um so I don't know I don't wanna maybe
if there's a season two they'll explore
that okay I like that that's fair uh and
then also you gotta Spill the Beans
about you know oh so she spills the
beans about doing intercom as Tris right
what on Earth was Sandra thinking here
this is where I scratched my head with
Sandra like what what give me your what
she was doing what's going on with this
yeah I mean I know Chris like in the
groom it was like um Chris and I would
have conversations all the time you're
like no she did this and it's terrible
I'm like having to defend her I'm like
no because I'm playing her um yeah and
that reading that was like oh
interesting choice but again she's so I
think she's a little bit naive in that
she thinks that she is the end-all
Beyond like knows a lot
um and then she's realizing yeah she's
growing that she doesn't know anything
um and so like you know with that I
think she was trying her best to like
push her friends in the right direction
or what she thought was the right
direction
and then she realized that like just
supporting them was something that was
was all they needed really yeah so yeah
good intention which I like and that's
what I like about the character of
Sandra and
with the finale you had mentioned you
know you talked about Possible season
two and we see she has an emotional
goodbye and says I don't want to go but
if a season two happens like kind of
what you were just saying do you think
there is more story for Sandra to be
told to be explored
I mean yeah I mean maybe I'd love to see
because now that she's going off I'd
love to see her a little bit happier
maybe
um I mean there's always so much to
explore with all of these characters
they're written so well and there's like
so much life in them but yeah I don't
know I don't want to say too much but
okay but to that point though with her
getting this news about healing is there
a part of her you think that
there's like she almost wishes it wasn't
her because you kind of get I guess
survivor's guilt right a little bit in a
sense and I mean like reading that and
trying to act that I was like this is
that was a stressful scene for me
because like how do you do that because
you know as a viewer you do think like
um if you haven't gone through something
similar to what she's going through then
you do things like you know oh when
you'd be so happy but she was so content
I think and that was her life and her
friends were her life you know what I
mean so now that she's um healing or
healing and having to start all over you
know because she's gonna have to do the
treatments and things again it's kind of
scary as well I guess yeah sure yeah so
that that's interesting too for sure I'd
love to see more of that explored and
then
also it says in other interviews I did
with other actors of the show but
I have to ask a question so it's so cool
that you guys got to play different
characters and different stories in the
Midnight Club was there any characters
in particular love playing besides the
giving a kiss Alice Palmer was there any
like fun set stories or anything you
just experienced that you really enjoyed
I mean in
heart and then in like it comes back
because because they could be story
comes back or something I got to do the
one of the Dead girls
because I was just upset with like a
giant gash and like blood and
Prosthetics in my hair that was my real
hair it's just like they just let it out
and I was like that was fun because it
was quite chill but I looked quite
terrifying yeah totally it came off
terrifying good job on that that was
great and then uh my last question for
you before I let you go is
what character in The Midnight Club did
anara relate to the most whether it is
Sandra or was there another character
just by you as a viewer that you kind of
spoke to you the most
oh
um
I guess maybe I mean I think I'm the
least like my character but maybe
but maybe a little bit Sandra just
because she always she's always like you
know a little bit since so like
pretentious but like she's always just a
little bit like on the outside kind of
and trying to figure out how to get in
if that makes sense um so I can relate
to her a little bit in that sense yeah
yeah no I love it that makes sense and
you've just been a great guest here
thank you for joining me today so
everybody watch and Nara just crush it
in the Midnight Club on Netflix tell
people about it re-watch it you'll catch
more stuff on the second watch whatever
thank you so much for joining me hope to
talk to you in the future one day thank
you